UNBELIEVABLE.
BRIAN, THANK YOU AND WE WANT YOU
IN THE MORNING, WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP TONIGHT.
BILLY BREAKING NEWS, MULTIPLE
FRONTS INCLUDING MORE BEER IN
VARIOUS THINGS BEFORE PETE I
MEAN, REALLY BAD ONES.
IT SEEMS SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY
UNCLE JOE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
STATE HE WAS IN AND IT GETS
WORSE.
HIS 2020 CAMPAIGN IS HANGING IN
THE BALANCE AND HE IS NOW IN
THIRD PLACE IN A MAJOR POLL.
ALSO, MAJOR UPDATE FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S ONGOING TRADE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH CHINA.
AT THE PRESIDENT IS WINNING.
THAT'S THE STAR APPEARED WE WILL
TELL YOU MORE ABOUT THAT BUT WE
BEGIN WITH SHOCKING NEW
DEVELOPMENT OUT OF THE
DEEP STATE.
WE CAN CONFIRM TONIGHT THAT THE
DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FISA
ABUSE, THAT'S THE
MICHAEL HOROWITZ REPORT, HAS NOT
BEEN COMPLETED AND ACCORDING TO
THE HILLS JOHN SOLOMON, THE IG'S
FINDINGS COULD BE RELEASED AS
EARLY AS THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS.
IT'S NOW BEING PROCESSED FOR
POTENTIAL REACTIONS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS HE EXPECTS
THE FINDINGS TO BE AND UGLY AND
HE WILL WANT ALL OF IT RELEASED
AND HE WILL GIVE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS MUCH TIME
AS HE NEEDS TO TELL THE ENTIRE
STORY OF THIS ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION.
NOW COURSE, ONE OF THE KEY
TARGETS OF THE INVESTIGATION IS
LIKELY MR. SUPER PATRIOT
HIMSELF, JIM COMEY.
AS WE ALL KNOW BY NOW, CALL ME
AND SIGNED OFF ON THE VERY FIRST
FIVES APPLICATION AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AND HIS CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE AND WE
ALSO NOW KNOW HE SIGNED TWO
OTHER PHASE APPLICATIONS ALL
BASED, THE BULK OF INFORMATION,
THE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
HE SWORE THREE TIMES THAT THE
EVIDENCE IN THOSE APPLICATIONS
WERE TRUE, ACCURATE, AND
VERIFIED.
IN REALITY, IN TRUTH, NONE OF IT
WAS ANY OF THE ABOVE.
IN NONE OF IT WAS TRUE, NONE OF
IT WAS VERIFIED AND CALL ME WAS
LYING.
NOW, THE FIRST PFIZER REQUEST
RELIED ON HILLARY'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DIRTY DOSSIER, RUSSIAN
DOSSIER, THAT WASN'T TRUE.
NEITHER WAS THE SECOND OR THIRD
WARRANT.
IT WAS ALL BASED ON THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
OUT OF IT ACCURATE, NONE OF IT
VERIFIABLE.
IT WAS ALL UNVERIFIABLE GARBAGE.
CALL ME THE INTEL WAS --
HE.
HE WAS BORN MORE SPECIFICALLY ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS AND MULTIPLE
PEOPLE AND SOURCES.
NO SERIOUS ATTEMPT WAS EVER MADE
TO VERIFY THE DOSSIER'S CLAIMS
THAT HE SIGNED OFF ON THREE
TIMES.
COMEY USED IT IN A WAY IN ORDER
TO SECURE A BACKDOOR INTO ALL
THINGS TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THEN
TRANSITION AND THEN THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY SO IT'S CLEAR
JIM COMEY CREMATED PREMEDITATED
FRAUD AND A PFIZER ORDER TO SPY
ON A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
MEANWHILE, COMEY'S RIGHT-HAND
MAN, FOR MEERUT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE WAS FIRED FROM THE
FBI LAST YEAR FOR LYING AND
LEAKING BUT GUESS WHAT?
McCABE WILL FIT RIGHT IN.
HE WAS JUST HIRED BY FAKE NEWS
CNN.
THEY CLAIMED TO BE THE FACTS
FIRST NETWORK BUT THEY CAN BREAK
A MILLION VIEWERS IN A SINGLE
HOUR OF PRAYER THAT IS A
DISASTER FOR ANY NETWORK.
BREAKING TIES WE SPEAK, FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS ARE NEARING A
FINAL DECISION ON WHETHER OR NOT
THE FORMER DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
McCABE WILL IN FACT BE
INDICTED OVER HIS EGREGIOUS
LYING.
WAIT A MINUTE, THEY WENT AFTER
AMANDA FORD FOR AND PAPADOPOULOS
FOR LYING AND COHEN FOR LYING
AND GENERAL PLAN FOR LYING, DO
WE HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER LAW?
AND GET THIS, AS FORMER
COLLEAGUE PRESIDENT TRUMP
LISA PAGE, SHE MAY BE THE
DECIDING FACTOR.
YOU'RE NOT TO ASK WHEN ALL OF
THIS BREAKING NEWS OUR VERY OWN
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT BREAK I THINK I'M A BIG
BREAKING STORY.
>> GOOD EVENING.
A SOURCE TO THE MATTER TELLS
FOX NEWS PROSECUTORS CLOSE TO A
DECISION OVER WHETHER TO CHARGE
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR AND ACTING
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE FOR LYING
TO THE INVESTIGATORS.
REPORTING ON A ANDREWS LEGAL
TEAM MET LAST WEEK WITH THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR D.C.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO PLAN A
COMMENT THAT THAT THESE MEETINGS
ARE OFTEN USED BY THE DEFENSE AS
THEIR EFFORT TO ARGUE AGAINST
OUR CLIENTS.
McCABE WAS FIRED LAST YEAR
AFTER THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL E
HORWITZ SAID HE LACKED CANDOR
UNDER OATH OVER HIS LATE ROLE IN
THE LEAK OF THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
THREE WEEKS AGO, McCABE FILED
HIS 48 PAGE LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
FBI FOR WRONGFUL TERMINATION AND
RECENTLY McCABE JOINED CNN AS
A COUNTER ROUTE ROUTER.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, HE TOLD THE
NETWORK AT THE ALLEGATIONS ARE
FALSE AND HE JOINT BLAMES THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAD AN
INDELIBLE IMPACT ON THE IG'S
PROCESS.
I KNOW THAT THE PROCESS THAT I
WENT THROUGH WAS ONE THAT WAS
UNFAIR, LEFT OUT MULTIPLE PIECES
OF RELEVANT INFORMATION, AND THE
TESTIMONY OF WITNESSES WHO WERE
NEVER REFERENCED IN THE REPORT.
>> REPORTS DID NOT RESPOND TO
REQUEST FOR COMMENT WHEN IT
COMES TO LYING OR LACK OF CANDOR
UNDER OATH.
WHAT MATTERS HERE ACCORDING TO
FORMER FBI AGENTS IS THAT THE
BUREAU IS HELD TO A HIGHER
STANDARD BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONES THAT ENFORCE THE LAW
CREATED >> Sean: I WILL TELL
YOU ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
UNFAIR.
DIDN'T McCABE TELL
LIEUTENANT GENERAL FLYNN THAT HE
DIDN'T NEED A LAWYER JUST PRIOR
TO CALL ME BRAGGING ABOUT
SENDING PEOPLE IN THAT HE WOULD
NEVER DO THAT IN THE BUSH ORB
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE CHAOS KNOWING
IT WAS AN INTERROGATION RUSSIAN
MARK WOULDN'T THAT BE --
TO ME THAT SOUNDS LIKE MIRANDA
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
THAT SEEMS UNFAIR IF THEY KNEW
IT WAS INVESTIGATION BUT I DON'T
WANT TO DRAG YOU INTO THE
NARRATIVE BUT THAT'LL HAPPEN,
RIGHT?
YOU GO IT'S ALL HOPEFULLY GO
INTO HOW MUCH COME UP IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS.
>> Sean: THEY DID BRAG ABOUT
IT.
THEY DID SAY YOU DON'T NEED A
LAWYER AND COMMENTED BRAGGED
THAT HE TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THE
CAST BUT HE WOULDN'T DO ANY
OBAMA BUSH ADMINISTRATIONS.
CLEAR REPORTING AS ALWAYS.
NOW WITHOUT A DOUBT IT WAS A BIG
WEEKEND FOR FAKE NEWS CNN ON TOP
OF THE HIRING OF THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR WHO WAS FIRED FOR LYING
AND LEAKING.
WELL, WE HAVE JEFF STUCKER
SONOGRAPHER BRIAN SELZER,
HUMPTY DUMPTY GIVING UP LOT FORM
TO SOME PRETTY SHOCKING
ACCUSATIONS LETTING IT GO
UNCHALLENGED.
OF COURSE, THIS ALL HAPPENING ON
A SPARSELY WATCHED LOW RATED
WEEKEND SHOW.
HUMPTY DUMPTY FEATURING A
DERANGED PSYCHOLOGIST FROM DUKE
CLAIMING TRUMP MAY BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MORE DEATHS THAN
HITLER, STALIN, AND MAO.
SPECIAL MONOLOGUE FOR A HOME TO
LATER IN THE PROGRAM AND
NATURALLY, HUMPTY DUMPTY AND
FAKE NEWS CNN ALSO DUTIFULLY
DEFENDED THEIR BIG NEW HIRE.
YOU KNOW, THEY DID FOR LYING AND
LEAKING, ANDREW MCCABE HERE BY
ANDREW MCCABE HERE BY THE WAY
COMEY WAS FIRED FROM THAT JOB AS
WE SAT UNDER THE SUPER PATRIOT
JIM COMEY.
NOW, McCABE MIGHT FACE
CRIMINAL CHARGES BUT ON
HUMPTY DUMPTY SHOW, McCABE WAS
HAILED FOR HIS QUOTE, SERIOUS
EXPERTISE.
WATCH.
>> CNN HIRED ANDREW MCCABE
FORMALLY FIRED FROM THE FBI
ACCUSED OF LYING AND LEAKING AND
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHTS OF ALL, YOU
ARE HIDING A McCABE, WHY CAN'T
A FOX HIRE SPICER?
WHY CAN'T A FOX HIGHER
STANDARDS?
IS THERE A DIFFERENCE COURSE ARE
MIXED THERE IS A DIFFERENCE.
McCABE HAS EXPERTISE WITH
RESPECT TO THE FBI AND HE IN NO
WAY WAS ACCUSED OF STANDING IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
LYING TO THEM.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF LACK OF CANDOR
IN TALKING ABOUT THE PRESS BUT
THE PROPORTION OF SCALE AND
SUBSTANCE ARE UTTERLY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Sean: SAME FAKE NEWS
NETWORK THAT HAS BEEN PEDDLING
LIES CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND THE
BIGGEST HOAX IN AMERICAN HISTORY
EVERY SINGLE MINUTES, SO I CAN
COME HOUR OF EVERY 24-HOUR DAY,
WEEK, MONTH, , AND YARDAGE IS TE
PRIME EXAMPLE OF WHY STELTER AND
HIS EMPLOYER, BY THE WAY, THE
PRESIDENT IS FOREVER RARELY
GRANTED THEM FAKE NEWS CNN THAT